hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
i've got a really important message
today
i'm standing right now in one of my most
favorite locations here's the beach
beautiful sandy beach um there's quite a
lot of people here
there's the ocean uh we're in sandbanks
however
one of the really interesting things
about the beach is this
it's everyone's dream location everyone
loves coming to the beach
it looks nice sandy beach
however it doesn't actually cost
any money to come to the beach so all
these people
that are lying on the beach dipping in
the ocean
it doesn't cost anything it's free that
really got me thinking
if it's free and it doesn't cost any
money why not more people
here and the reason they're not here
is because they're at work right
they're working it's a it's a weak day
so it's not because they can't afford it
so people think they need more money
but really they don't need more money
what they actually need is they need
more time see the best things in life
i believe are free but might as well
cost the earth if you haven't got the
time
to enjoy them and it's 28 degrees
celsius right now
rarely gets that hot in england and the
beach
is empty because everybody is at work
so you know maybe you've been thinking
you need to be a millionaire
you know you need to be making 20 grand
a month 30 grand a month to live your
dream life but actually
apart from a nice house and a nice car
things in life don't really cost that
much
you don't need to be a millionaire you
might want to be a millionaire
it might be nice to be a millionaire you
don't need to make 20 30 40 50 60 grand
a month
you don't need to drive a lamborghini i
don't have a lamborghini
i could very easily afford one
i don't like them that much what i want
is i want time
and i realize that when you have time
suddenly life that your quality of life
goes up massively
so how do you do that well to have more
time
you just need to earn a different type
of income instead of earning
active income you need to earn you need
to learn to earn passive income
when you learn to earn passive income
you realize you don't need that much of
it
you know two to five thousand pounds a
month
in passive income should set most people
up for life
then you can come to the beach and do
what you want live a great life
so in this video what i'm going to do is
i want to talk about the best
ways to earn passive income and i
believe by a mile
the number one way to earn passive
income is through
property it's through real estate
because if you own a piece of property
and you rent it out ow shagger raga naga
these green things man they hurt your
feet if um
if you're on a piece of real estate and
you rent it out
you're going to get rent every single
month
and that rent is going to become your
income and if you've got a few
properties
and you've got enough income that covers
your bills
then guess what you can hang at the
beach every day if you want
what you'll probably realize is when you
start hanging at the beach every day
you'll realize that actually gets pretty
boring so you'll probably end up
setting up other businesses and going on
to set up charities
have a mission kind of like what i've
done but to start with get financially
free
so how are you going to get a few houses
how are you going to do that
maybe you haven't got any money well you
can do that using strategies like rent
to rent
rent a property for cheap and then rent
it like you see
these um these apartments down here
oh my goodness you can rent these
apartments for like
300 pounds a night a night
in fact anywhere around the whole
proximity of this beach
to rent an apartment or to rent a hotel
you're talking
200 to 500 pounds a night however
there's apartments that you can rent for
a thousand pounds a month
so you rent out the apartment and then
re-rent it out on airbnb booking.com
as a hotel systemize it guess what that
gives you it gives you passive income
you don't have to own it you can just
control it another thing you can do is
you can do lease option agreements
you can buy a property now with the with
the option
to pay for it later and in the meantime
what are you gonna do you're gonna rent
it out
you're gonna benefit from rental income
you're gonna benefit from
the capital appreciation you don't even
own the house
you've paid a one pound option fee and
some legal fees
so in this video what i wanted to get
you doing and i'm gonna go jump back in
the ocean
is i wanted to get you thinking about
passive income as opposed to active
income
and i wanted to get you thinking
actually
you don't need that much of it for it to
completely change your life
you know so stop worrying about becoming
a millionaire one day or
driving a lamborghini saving up loads of
money
start thinking about making two to five
thousand pounds a month
but in passive income meaning the type
of income that you earn whether you go
to work or not
hope you found this video helpful if you
did hit like subscribe for more videos
i'll see you next time